This tiny heart is about to
beat for the very first time...
In this moment, a cluster of developing cells
begins a rhythmic pulse that will last a lifetime.
But why now? What triggers the heart to start
beating at this precise moment?
And how do all the cells start to contract in synchrony?
For each heart there's only one chance to catch that very first beat
so scientistshave been using microscopes, fluorescent proteins, arrays of zebrafish embryos
and a lot ofpatience to explore this pivotal moment...
These are zebrafish embryos
each less than one millimeter long.
Their hearts start beating only 20 hours
after fertilization, well before the growing
organism actually needs its heart functions.
To visualize the heartbeats, the researchers used fluorescent proteins which glowin response to their surroundings.
Here the pink fluorescent proteins represent a
voltage spike which causes a spike of Calciumions,
seen here in green. And it's this calcium
spike which causes the cells to contract.
In the adult fish, the beating of the heart is
controlled by a pacemaker region, a group of
cells which control the speed of contractions in
the rest of the organ.
But for the first heartbeats the researchers found no clear pacemakers;
differentembryos had different cells that started beating first
and they triggered the cells around themin a wave-like pattern.
In this experiment the cells in the bottom left of this image startthe pulse which travels across the heart.
But when researchers silenced those cells,
thisregion of cells takes over
as the starting point of each pulse.
So what starts the process? What
kicks off the chain reaction?
The answer is: perhaps nothing in particular.
It seems that as thecells mature in the developing embryo they grow gradually more and more sensitive to electrical
signals.
After a while they become so sensitive to natural electrical noise in the tissue around them
that some of the cells start activating at random.
This activates the cells next to them and the
ones next to those and so on until a pulse spreads
across the heart for the first time.
Gradually,eventually, a steady rhythm is established.
The team think that this is how those very first
heartbeats originate - in quite a haphazard way.
Very different to the tightly controlled rhythm of
the adult heart.
Understanding this key point in development
could help researchers study
what goeswrong in embryos with congenital heart conditions.
Or it could be useful for engineering stemcells that can be implanted into a damaged heart
and which need to sync up with the
rhythm of the patient's own heart tissues.
The heart works continuously during
its lifetime, through adrenaline rushes
and exhaustion until our final moments...
but itcouldn't happen without that very first heartbeat.